[Música]
então como vocês quando tinha 16 anos eu
estava estudando é na verdade é eu
estava como acho que todos vocês é no
ensino médio em uma escola em barbacena
e como toda a cidade é da mantiqueira
mineira
ou você faz ouvindo você tá descendo
está fazendo alguma curva porque andar
em linha reta no plano é impossível é
bom eu acho que nessa época da minha
vida eu acho que eu aprendi várias
coisas como o que é a democracia
revolução francesa é o que aquela camada
de ozônio ou a evolução das espécies e
biodiversidade é eletromagnetismo
computadores
é o que é uma célula que quer vírus o
que a aids
a questão é em que medida no brasil hoje
os jovens têm acesso à educação é em que
medida é isso importa
ou seja será que esse jovem estava na
escola não será que importa e que medita
que a sociedade brasileira está
comprometida em colocar todos os jovens
na escola em que medida a sociedade
brasileira está se esforçando para
colocar todos os jovens na escola e no
final do dia em que medida é que nós
estamos se nós já não já colocamos todos
os jovens na escola em que medida nós
estamos caminhando na direção de colocar
todos os jovens na escola
então isso é o que a gente vai conversar
hoje talvez nada melhor do que conversar
é começar isso pelo é é e em 1988 quando
nós tivemos é é instalada uma nova
constituição em 1988
nós tínhamos metade dos nossos jovens de
15 a 17 anos a não ser que eu estava
falando de jovens aqui está falando
jovens adolescentes de 15 a 17 anos
nós temos em 88 achamos metade dos
nossos jovens fora da escola portanto
essa idéia que estou falando aqui era um
pouco alienígena é e nós víamos na
verdade não tinha essa curva que não se
continue sendo que estava meio que
parado há pelo menos uma década
logo após é é a nossa nova constituição
o brasil mudou de ruim educacionalmente
e nós caminhamos durante dez anos na
direção de aumentar a nossa proporção de
jovens na escola
se aqui nós de cada quatro nós tínhamos
dois fora da escola aqui de cada quatro
a gente passou a ter só e fora da escola
muitos de nós quando chegou aqui falar
isso aqui tá indo
é uma maravilha deixa me preocupar com
outra coisa porque afinal de contas se
isso é que já tá mais ou menos resolvido
a questão de tempo em 2012
o problema estará resolvido em mil
outros problemas que eu tenho que me
preocupar com problemas de violência e
problemas reais e outros problemas de
pobreza e desigualdade e etc
então eu podia dormir tranquilamente
porque esse problema estava equacionado
é infelizmente aqueles que passaram esse
tempo sem prestar atenção nesse problema
na hora que eles acordam é em 2015 ou
eles vão levar um susto porque a curva
na verdade virou essa daqui
ou seja a gente hoje tem e de cada cinco
jovens de 15 a 17 anos fora a da escola
e nós não progredimos praticamente nada
ao longo dos últimos 17 anos
será que isso é uma crise mundial
eu queria mostrar para vocês o seguinte
que na verdade o brasil com o seu é é o
brasil com o seu fantástico crescimento
zero tem 80% dos países do mundo
à frente dele com crescimento positivo
de 80% dos países do mundo conseguiram
avançar na direção de colocar os seus
jovens de 15 a 17 anos na escola
o brasil está entre aqueles pobres
coitados que não estão conseguindo botar
os seus jovens na escola
se a gente olhar a américa latina é se a
gente olhar a américa latina está aqui
se a gente olhar o mundo a média do
mundo tá aqui
ou seja o brasil tá fazendo um trabalho
muito aquém do que tem feito a américa
latina eo mundo
então nós abandonamos
aparentemente o nosso sonho de todo
jovem na escola né enquanto que o resto
do mundo não abandonou esse sonho
a pergunta é será que
é essa idéia de ter todos os jovens na
escola
alguma hora foi realmente um compromisso
da sociedade brasileira
algo que nós realmente queríamos
olha na verdade você olhar a nossa
constituição ela diz no artigo 208 que
todo jovem de 4 a 17 anos
devia estar obrigatoriamente na escola
o nosso plano nacional de educação que
demorou quatro anos sendo discutido no
congresso foi aprovado e diz que em 2016
que não estou errado já passou é é todo
jovem é devia tá na escola
nós temos um plano nacional que dizia
que todos os jovens até 17 anos shakhtar
na escola e obviamente não tá
e isso quer dizer o seguinte sempre que
nós nos comprometemos com nós mesmos é é
nós estamos dizendo todo jovem da escola
mais curioso é que quando nós nos
comprometemos com o resto do mundo e nós
nos comprometemos com o resto do mundo
quando nós nos comprometemos com a
declaração universal dos direitos
humanos que o brasil foi um dos grandes
signatários eo alguém estava sentado na
primeira fila
lutando pela declaração universal dos
direitos humanos emoções 48 em paris e
lagos que toda pessoa tem direito à
educação
mas os nossos jovens continuam tempo
mais do que isso em 2015
nós tivemos a última conferência de
chefes de estado para discutir o futuro
da educação no mundo o brasil foi um dos
líderes dessa conferência mundial o que
que tá dito nessa conferência que todos
os jovens com pelo menos 12 anos de
escolarização primária e secundária
gratuita pública inclusiva equitativa e
de qualidade
o brasil é o grande signatário e um dos
autores e um dos defensores dessa a aaa
dessa declaração
ou seja nós estamos internamente
compromissados
nos comprometemos com todo mundo
queríamos colocar todos os nossos jovens
na escola mas até hoje a gente não
colocou e parece que nos últimos 20 anos
a gente está caminhando da maneira
inacreditavelmente lenta
a pergunta é como talvez isso não seja
tão importante quem ele se comprometeu o
que a gente é acha que é importante será
que realmente importante
então eu trouxe aqui um gráfico para
vocês um golo de graf que ele mostra o
seguinte olha é toda a sociedade que é
ter uma renda maior
dá mais uma sociedade relativamente
pobre com uma brasileira
a única maneira da gente é ter mais
coisas a única maneira de a gente ter
uma casa melhor é que as pessoas
produzam mais tijolos e cimento né então
nós precisamos produzir mais para poder
ter uma vida melhor ea gente acredita
que a educação vai ajudar a gente a
produzir mais
ou seja mais educação deve trazer mais
produtividade mais produtividade quer
dizer que nós vamos ter melhor qualidade
de vida se obviamente não é escolher é
como que a gente vai aproveitar toda
essa fartura e essa riqueza que está à
nossa disposição é esse gráfico ele
mostra o seguinte como que no shine um
aumento na a educação de 3 série g é
estudo em 30 anos né 1980 a 2010 o chile
aumentou 3 sérios e arrenda o a
produtividade dos trabalhadores aumentou
10 mil dólares por trabalhador por ano
ou seja o chile subir uma rampa que há
uma rampa interessante mais educação
mais produtividade
a educação é importante por várias
razões é um direito humano
ninguém está dizendo que vai fazer
educação para aumentar a produtividade
mas é bom que a educação aumente a
produtividade tem mais
uma razão para dizer que todo jovem tem
que estar na escola na opel chile
mas será que isso vale em todo lugar do
mundo então a gente botou aqui por
exemplo a malásia uma loja está subindo
uma rampa também a rampa da malásia é
ter uma inclinação de dois e meio do
chile tem três ea china têm três e mail
né porque o chile está lá em cima ea
china para aqui em baixo porque é muito
mais fácil para o chile que é tem muito
recurso natural é como minas gerais é
ser rico do que a china que tem
relativamente pouco recurso natural e
também tem um recurso natural ficar lá
em cima a gente importa que o chile
subiu a málaga subiu a china subida que
tal gente só pra entretenimento nós
se a gente colocasse a coreia e sabe que
a coréia é um caso à parte
vamos botar aqui só pra entretenimento
na hora que a gente bota correta isso
aqui é ou seja eles aumentam a educação
ea produtividade vai lá em cima porque
eles têm uma educação inacreditavelmente
conectada com atividade econômica é uma
educação que realmente modifica a
produtividade
então há evidência que se gente educação
além de ser um direito humano além da
nossa constituição nosso plano nacional
de educação é importantíssima para
melhorar a qualidade da nossa vida
o brasil também na hora que a gente bota
o brasil ocupa e é algo errado aqui pra
isso eu voltar aqui que pode ser que
chovesse eu entendi está dizendo que
aumenta a escolaridade do país aumenta a
produtividade
o brasil horizontal não é ruim tá errada
quando não é isso mesmo é que no brasil
a educação ea economia atividade
econômica eles não conversam muito bem o
nível de diálogo entre a educação ea
atividade econômica não não é muito bom
então o brasil ele ele precisa
urgentemente ressignificar a sua
educação ou seja educação no brasil
precisa talvez demais significa
cadu para a melhoria da qualidade de
vida das pessoas já que a educação tem
que é te ajudar a ser não só uma pessoa
melhor não só fazer com que você possa
ter capacidade de escolher melhor aquilo
qual é a vida que você quer pra você
mesmo mas também te ajudar a ser uma
pessoa mais produtiva e tal maneira que
você não possa só sonhar mas se possa
realizar coisas
há até um certo desentendimento entre a
educação brasileira ea nossa economia
a nossa educação ela definitivamente não
serve o capitalismo mas não tem problema
a gente tem que dar uma ressignificação
a nossa educação mas isso é talvez é um
tema para uma outra conversa é que eu
queria mostrar a vocês o seguinte que a
educação e todo lugar do mundo traz
produtividade no brasil está trazendo
mais gente
vamos dar um jeito nisso mas a educação
mesmo no brasil ela tem impactos
impressionante
então aqui por exemplo eu peguei pessoas
é é o azul é uma pessoa que é é fez o
ensino médio eo vermelho é alguém que
não fez o ensino médio
ah e é o azul ali ele está ganhando uma
renda de 1.142 reais por mês enquanto
que o que não fez o ensino médio ganham
500 ou seja você ir para o ensino médio
dobra a tua renda mesmo que você vai
parar ali no final do ensino médio
se você botar lhe o acesso a um trabalho
formal dobra o teu acesso a um emprego
formal
se você é pegar o impacto sobre a
fecundidade enquanto que alguém que
completou o ensino médio é o azul vai
ter
aos 35 anos dois filhos quem não
completou o ensino médio deve ter três
filhos é tão reduz a fecundidade e à
propriedade de que o seu filho vai
completar o ensino médio na idade
correta também praticamente dobra
nós criamos um
a medida de é quando você alcança a sua
qualidade de vida
então nós definimos aqui sem é aquela
pessoa que vai conseguir ter a qualidade
de vida dos seus sonhos é é é
realisticamente é definida é o que a
gente vê o seguinte quem faz o ensino
médio
alcança 83% desse potencial de qualidade
de vida
quem não é é faz o ensino médio alcança
no máximo é 49% da sua qualidade de vida
então a educação é importa e ela importa
bastante o brasil está comprometido e
educação importa então o que está
acontecendo aqui nós não vamos fazer
nada e na hora que a gente olha tá vendo
esse mapa
nós fizemos um levantamento será que nós
estamos fazendo alguma coisa nós
encontramos 135 programas de governos
estaduais e da sociedade civil e de
alguns governos municipais diretamente
envolvido em traver e manter o jovem na
escola
então o que está aqui quer dizer o
seguinte é que no final do dia é
indicada cinco jovens brasileiros lá
fora da escola e 17 anos que a gente não
consegue avançar
mas o brasil sempre aspirou que todos
estivessem na escola e nós sabemos que a
escola é muito importante e além disso
nós sabemos que o brasil com
criatividade com esforço tentando 135
soluções
logo que está faltando nessa história
nós temos que mudar nós temos que
recuperar a nosso rumo à universalização
nós temos que universalizar o acesso à
caçam para jovens de 15 a 17 anos no
brasil está na nossa constituição
nós estamos comprometidos com isso isso
é possível
nós já fizemos no passado uma subida
importante nós temos que sair dessa
paralisia e voltar a crescer como é que
nós vamos voltar a crescer
ora dentro destas 135 coisas que nós
estamos tentando fazer
deve ter a solução além disso 80% dos
países do mundo tão colocando os jovens
na escola deve ter alguma coisa processo
aprendida e copiada da experiência
desses países
logo nós precisamos não só de
compromisso e de esforço mas nós
precisamos de resolutividade
nós precisamos de uma política
educacional que não só é compromissada e
é esforçada mas que ela alcança os
resultados que ela tem alcançar para
alcançar o resultado que eu tenho
alcançar
ela tem que analisar no detalhe é 635
tentativas e ver qual delas funciona e
fazer e apostar e colocar os recursos
nessas que funcionam então tem que olhar
para o mundo ver o que funciona lá fora
que a gente pode copiar e copiar sem
medo de copiar
se você quiser saber mais
nós fizemos um amplo estudo sobre toda
essa questão se você quiser é saber mais
e por que colocar todos os jovens na
escola é tão importante e como que
colocar todos os jovens na escola pode
ser alcançado números de uma maneira
viável é você pode olhar para o nosso
estudo nesse site
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]